following on from ubisoft's announcement
of the division franchise moving in a
direction that will include more games
and more transmedia content
set within the division universe we've
been presented with yet
another surprise
[Music]
early this morning my time the ubisoft
twitter account announced the following
calling all agents of tom clancy's the
division we're bringing it to life
in audio for the first time listen out
for the division hearts on fire
landing on 15th of july
the division is getting a new audio
drama called hearts on fire
hearts on fire will be based on a time
before the existing game franchise
a prequel to the division one the story
follows a new recruit called hoskins
we'll be following hoskin's journey as
she is recruited and brought into the
ranks of the shd
all while maintaining her day job as a
firefighter and paramedic in new york
city
until one day a biological attack
strikes down the city
sending it to the brink of collapse
hoskins along with their training
partner and fellow agent are tasked with
following the path of a growing hostile
presence
calling themselves the cleaners this
brutal group has been taking matters
into their own hands in an attempt to
restore order to manhattan
manipulating the current situation they
have been recruiting the desperate
and easily influenced including hoskins
sister and former us army veteran
joanna joanna has been struggling to
adjust to normal
since leaving the army and joining the
cleaners offered a sense of familiarity
to her life
in a time when everything around her
seems to be falling apart
as things continue to get out of hand
hoskins is ultimately forced to decide
between
a duty and a family
[Music]
hearts on fire has been called an
audible original which is an american
online audiobook and podcast service
owned by amazon this is ubisoft's second
collaboration with audible after
assassin's creed gold
last year heart on fire has been created
by award-winning director
kc weyland and features katie sakhoff
known for her work in the mandalorian
and battlestar galactica and shannon
woodward from the last of us part two
and westworld i am obviously very
excited about this any addition to the
story has my full support
i wonder if we'll be hearing about any
new information for example will we get
more detail around the shd recruitment
process
and will we hear from joe ferro but
probably the biggest question burning in
my mind
where was my invite i would have totally
got some vocal lessons for this
i wonder what else they have in mind for
the extra transmedia content towards the
division universe
i'm calling it now division the musical
anyway this was just a quick update in
response to the earlier news
let me know what you think cheers
[Applause]
[Music]